welcome to ear biscuits
I'm rent and I'm link this week at the
round table of dim lighting we're gonna
get some wisdom because we are going to
review some sage advice yeah we asked
you what the best advice you've ever
received was and that was because we
were asked that question by Stannah us
who asked us on Twitter what is the best
advice someone has ever given you with
the most impact on your life and we were
like you know what that's a good
question but we'll answer that we're
gonna try to answer that but we're also
we set that question back to you and got
all the advice that you thought was the
most impactful in your entire life and
we're gonna go through and evaluate
whether or not it's good advice no we're
we're just gonna go through and take the
advice that you've taken to heart to
heart and discuss and discuss what was
that the end of your Center and discuss
discuss we're going to discuss it it i
think it's an is unnecessary in that
sentence I think there's a we need to
put a disclaimer at the top of this
thing so just bear with me I know you're
gonna do a probably 65 thing know what
I'm this podcast has been known by the
state of California to potentially cause
cancer I saw that on my freakin fiber
supplement what yeah was it the bottle
or was the pills that you're swallowing
it was the bag of just is it psyllium
husk fiber that I take if I need to
regulate myself which I don't take it
very much anymore bag you'd get you
might get but no it had a sticker on it
that I've never seen before it I got
this like you know I got like the
natural stuff that's supposed to be the
purest it's just 100% psyllium husk and
then all of a sudden there's this thing
this sticker and it's like prop 65 but
it's it doesn't say this substance or
substance in this bag has been known to
cause cancer in City California it says
see like prop 65 dot-gov slash food or
whatever the address might what you
why so it's not talking about the
container I think it's just like you
shaking about you should know about
foods to watch out for I don't know no I
brought it up I'm just gonna say um
advices a certain type of opinion and as
you know opinions are like buttholes
everybody's got one and most of them
stink so that tells me that advice is
like a butthole farting in your specific
direction it's an implication that like
I've got a unsolicited advice I've got
an opinion on something you should do so
you got we got it you gotta be careful
that you're sniffing the fart of
somebody that is worthy of sniffing I
think unsolicited advice is like a
butthole but solicited about no opinions
are like a butthole but advice in fact
of opinion advice is a is a fart
directed at you but if I ask you for
your opinion on something it's not like
a butthole anymore if I give you advice
unsolicited then yeah yeah I mean you
need to evaluate the source of the
advice which we're not gonna do here I'm
gonna take I think solicited opinions
are just like a whole ass just not as
you know I'm saying it's like but the
butthole you know I'm saying that in it
but I'm also saying that advice in
general is an opinion directed at you
it's an implication like this is my
opinion on what you should do with
yourself how you should conduct yourself
yeah you know so we're in dangerous
territory here you got to watch the
farts you sniffing but we're not giving
any of ice we're just evaluating advice
that people have been given so we're not
showing our asses at all and we pick
stuff that's resonated with us you know
I think this is gonna be an uplifting
conversation and it better be because it
needs to last for three more weeks
because I hate to break it to you dear
brisket ear but we're gonna go dark for
the next three weeks we're taking our
break we're taking a break three weeks
with no ear biscuits but there's a lot
of your biscuits that you can go back
and listen to there's also you know what
I hate to say I mean there's also other
podcasts I mean that is a thing you can
also listen to just over the next three
weeks just go back through our podcast
I'm sure there's something that you that
you missed I hear that people listen to
multiple times because they're doing
stuff when they're listening to it and
you know you you kind of fall in and out
of get of fifty percent or less yeah
anyway even if you're listening intently
yeah I mean I probably need to listen to
him over the next three weeks cuz why
don't you do that I I'm sure I miss some
stuff you ever listened to an episode of
your biscuits I listen to I listen to
myself when I'm speaking and sometimes I
listen to you and your speak right but
no I have not listened back to and your
biscuit in a long time maybe ever I
think when we first we first started
making these out but maybe the
interviews maybe I was listening in
order to figure out what it is we wanted
to do yeah it's quite a time commitment
to listen to yourself for over an hour
when you've already there and if yeah if
you put it if you put it on double speed
or something you really can't let it
just sounds weird you really don't learn
that much you miss all the emotion but
we guess I think it's working well
enough for me not to try to make it
better we're gonna answer that question
ourselves before the break not before
the break that we just talked about the
three week break but like before the
break where we do our add what you're
talking about we're gonna answer the
question we're gonna answer the question
about what our best piece of advice was
when right now yeah okay well then just
do it you tell them how to break like
we're about to take one well we're gonna
take one eventually eventually but not
the three week when you start talking
about break here's when I listen back to
our podcast here's the one thing I've
learned don't talk about a break if
you're not gonna take it because then
people think you're about to take it
yeah eventually yeah we'll take you know
we're not about to take a break
eventually
we're still doing the show we haven't
even gotten started you're talking about
taking a break I have some advice that I
have used
I just feel myself saying it and we say
it all the time it's what you make it
it's what you make it it's what you make
it and I always say it like that
it's what you make like you're quoting
someone right and yeah I think that's
been driving me nuts
he's not remembering who gave us the
advice but I'll give you I'll tell you
what I do know it was in the context of
a person talking about marriage
it's what you make it but I've used it
in many many different arenas you know
me and my wrists life in general yeah
you know it's it's what you make it's
what you make it it's up it's up to you
now as we will see when we get into some
of these other questions and it's not
completely up to you but it's a good
like when you think about a situation
that you're entering into it's like how
do you and I think the thing that guy
was talking about was like how do you
have a good marriage and it's just like
it's what you make it
I think I just know cuz I would have
been like did is this something Greg
said in college no cuz Greg said you
don't learn you know what you know you
don't learn anything when I was getting
ready to study for a test
yeah clear ulterior motives in that
pieces in sage which I gotta say while I
have used that conveniently for my own
purposes I do not think it's good advice
because I do actually think you learn
things I think that I hope I hope I
think you learn things I think there is
capacity for learning I think I've
learned some things but I think it was
it's what you make it at the one of the
fall retreats are you are you sure
you're not getting it confused with it's
part of it like like as the Dale
Earnhardt quote that's part of it when
it's like that's that's racing that's
what I thought Earnhardt said I say that
a lot but to do stuff that people did
you know he would he would driving away
- he would clanging and banging up
against the other cars and get a little
rowdy and be like that's racing I think
that's a Earnhardt quote I don't know
well it would be a Waltrip quote I'd
I've never watched an entire NASCAR race
you're saying that's racing is it is the
race
version of that's part of it you're not
saying that Dale Earnhardt came up with
that's part of it because I think that I
think got --have man came up with that's
part of it like I think that as soon as
the language was a thing someone said
that's part of it and that's not really
advice it's just kind of a saying right
it life is what you make it
but like what you make it is advice
because this because I feel like advice
is implying a state of mind it well it's
also a advice focus on what you can
control is an opportunity to do
something right or do not do something
but there's there is a response that is
intended from advice every moment of
your life you never get back but I think
that it was at that fall retreat one of
those followed treats that we went to
his students involved with Campus
Crusade and it was like the guy who was
speaking there and I think he was doing
a talk on marriage he also talked about
genital warts I mean that's one of the
things that I remember vividly I wasn't
there was it were there photos no his
opening his opening salvo who's this
health class like Conan Bunch
I typically remember it he told a story
about a man who did something like had
promiscuous sex or cheated on his wife
or something and it was disliked and
that man got genital warts and I was
like whoa we're going here alright okay
what does that mean and then he was like
and that man wasn't me and it's like
whoa what you've got genital warts and
and so I was not there for this okay
what are you remembered you would
remember that you you think he and then
he was like and genital warts or what
she makeup what no and then because the
way that they did the faller treats yeah
if you get the warts
there was always it was a guy that's
what you make there was a guy he was
always a guy who spoke the entire
weekend and so his opening talk was
genital warts and I mean he had us he
had us by the genital warts at that
point it was like whatever this guy says
we're don't miss any of the main talks
right because he opened with genital
warts and then he went to just talking
about relationships and marriage or
something and I kind
swear he said it's what you make it it
didn't seem revolutionary at the time
and I don't necessarily think that it is
revolutionary but the question was that
is impacted you the most and I just find
myself in situations all the time and
I'm like it's what you make it it's it
has been helpful as a joke but also as a
reality because it it helps you focus on
what you can control in any given
situation as opposed to the parts that
you can't I think we'll come back to
that you know I think there's some
advice it you know it's not just is the
advice good but it's who is the advice
for you know it's like the advice that
has always resonated with me is anything
worth doing is worth doing right but
that's a bit problematic for a guy like
me that I could get gets over focused on
the rightness of things and going about
them and the right because you might not
do something if you don't think you can
do it right yeah there is a there is
there's some fear and trepidation if
that rings in my ears too much and then
it's okay you know it's it's never clear
cut I'd like to believe that it is say
okay this is perfected I can move on so
it's you know you got to you got to
balance all these things
Nana's virtue my Nana's version of that
was don't half-ass it right you know
which we've talked about I've had a hard
time like there's not a lot of mottos
that ring in my head that have that were
once just pieces of advice I remember
when we were going on a trip to shoot
some videos a guy told me a guy who I
admire he said hey just remember it's
better to have a good story than a good
time in it and I was like you know I
kind of like that because we're trying
to make a if you're in a and I've talked
about this before on the show if you're
in a situation and it's it sucks you're
like well at least I can tell a story
about it because I have a podcast or you
have friends
or people who listen to yeah I like
telling a good story so that's that's
always helped give me perspective when
I'm going through something crappy but
it's a little bit weird to say it before
you're in that situation well but
especially because I think that being
present is actually yeah a better advice
that's not what I understand if you're
going through a difficult time this is
like better to have a good story than a
good time like if you're in the middle
like it's one of those crazy
I think it's vacations where
everything's gone but at least like I'll
be able to if I live to tell it I will
tell and usually what I say in those
situations is well this makes a great
story like I'm in the middle of I mean
I'm up shits Creek without a paddle but
at least it's a good story and it's been
like you said especially when you have a
place to tell the story but I don't
think that if I'm getting ready to like
go do something fun better to have a
good story than a good time is good
advice because what about when I'm what
about the joy that is pret is available
for me in the present yeah I don't think
it was great advice in this sense but I
still really liked it you know
well what about remember who you are you
know like parents send their kids out
into some something that they're gonna
do and they they come to the front door
and they're like hey hey remember who
you are
have you ever said I don't your children
uh sometimes I'd be like remember you're
Neil hahahaha
and what is that supposed to communicate
don't embarrass me don't say that often
and I'm not to tell you I don't I I just
don't fit I don't find myself ever
giving like these quotable pieces of
advice to my kids it's a maybe yeah it's
not quotable not bite-size it's more but
what I am guilty of and I know you're
just as guilty of it as I am
is giving advice in general to our kids
and and this it's actually something
that
it's something that Jesse and I have
talked a lot about is that sometimes we
get into a conversation with our kids
like they're just telling us about their
day they're telling us about something
they did or something they're going to
do and then there's like this dad button
that gets pressed and the dad button and
you get their signs well now well if
you're gonna do that think about this or
did you do what did you what did that
happen what did you learn that blah blah
blah
it's like unsolicited if you've got a
friend who talks like that like every
single time they tell you something you
tell them something there they give you
advice about it it's like that's not
what do you think I am a screw-up I'm
telling you this so we can connect
because I thought you might find it
interesting because you might be able to
add something to it
or you might be able to respond to it
with a perspective yeah but not to
didn't tell me what I should have done
differently or what I should have kept
in mind yeah I do that with my kids too
often I find when my kids talk about
their friends like things that are
happening with their friends I'm I'm
apparently filtering the conversation
through an analysis of do I approve of
their friends do I you know because your
friends are so powerful
that's probably is probably a piece of
advice in it you are here you hang out
with or something I kept your version of
that but I think that I filter things
through that platitude so then when
they're just talking about their day or
something that happened I'm like well
you know if you're that that type of
person is not if they if they do that
then that's not really a true friend a
true friend is someone who robbed a Baba
blah you know I end up analyzing and
trying to protect but you I guess you
want to get to a point where they're
they're actually its solicited advice
well if they're asked and hey I'm in
this situation or this person said this
to me I don't know how to respond or you
know and if they don't do that I think
that they're and I'm don't have this
perfected I don't even have it like
remedial II understood but the thing
that I'm trying to do now is ask
questions
in a way that it's not like a detective
not like a leading question so I seem
like a manipulating bit okay I'm having
this conversation there is something
that I feel like I need to communicate
about this because I still do have
advice I have been around longer I have
a perspective on this and I think of
their own wisdom Alevis and our kids
left to their own devices don't ask for
advices right and so then I'll ask a
question I mean my kids are smart enough
to know that I'm what I'm getting at but
at least it doesn't come across like
well did you know here is the thing that
I'm going to tell you but it's more like
have you thought about this or how you
feeling about that at least it gets them
talking and maybe you get someplace
where they come to a conclusion I don't
know it's tough being a dad but you know
what we don't have to come with all the
advice we've got some great advice from
people we're gonna start going through
it but first we're just gonna gently
advise you to check out mythical calm
you know we say it every week but every
week there's a little something new
there sales going on there's stuff going
on there's I mean there's you think we
got hoodies you think we got t-shirts
yeah we got that but we got lots other
stuff like pins and stickers and well
and we've got the whole feel good
mythical morning ensemble that we came
up with we had to feel good mythical
morning hoodie but now we got the feel
good mythical morning t-shirt
we got the feel good mythical morning
sticker and enamel pin so if you want to
feel good that's how that's our advice
feel good if it feels good do it and if
you need some help with that just go to
mythical calm okay let's get started
sometimes I tell tell my kids don't
think just do that's probably and I run
what context usually when it's like
they're standing on the edge of a pool
and they're afraid to jump in because
it's cold I was gonna say in like an
athletic context yeah
that's that's great advice because the
thinking in the doing is supposed to be
happening in sync if you're thinking
you've already the guys already gone
around you
but if I also jumped in the pool it's
also ironic because it it's not what I
want them to do and their non-athletic
lives which is the vast majority of
their lives that's not like no kites
yeah your kids are not at my kids my
kids are not sports kids yeah but I'm
gonna say they're not athletic they just
might not be like super into sports but
like if you like threw like a hot dog
out and they probably catch it don't you
think
I'll test ride that I'll test that today
that's the ultimate test of athleticism
throw a hot dog straight from the fridge
right at your child's face and if it
hits him in the face
you know what hopefully they're smart
because they're an addict okay give me
some advice Ariana bear squeals on
Twitter
my grandma their skulls but the U is a V
yeah I was just trying to be phonetic my
grandmother always used to tell me look
towards the sunshine and the shadows
will fall behind you that's true from
from like a physics standpoint every
time the Sun is out it makes me feel
like she's watching over me and making
sure I'm taking care of myself I mean it
isn't it so sweet too if you have these
memories of grandparents or someone that
means something to you that like even if
they passed that they passed along
something that can can echo like that
and for it to be so positive look
towards the sunshine actually be
positive and the shadows will fall
behind you I think there's a and it's I
I consider myself a generally positive
person and I think it's but I think is
more of a coping mechanism with me it's
like it's like if I can convince myself
that when things are not going well
because that does happen I'll you know
I'll feel better if I can minimize but
I've I've met some people that I seem
more like genuinely positive people they
have like a gift for it they can you
know they can turn from the shadow and
see the and see the sunshine maybe
they're just so good at applying this
kind of advice
there's secretly there you know there
catastrophizing but the advice is for
people who don't have a natural gift at
it because they don't need the advice so
and it does involve you know you you can
make a choice in any situation what
you're going to focus on and and how how
you're gonna see it how you're gonna
process it I mean this advice has been
given in a lot of different contexts you
know you've got keep on the sunny side
of life that great song but then lock
and I actually had this conversation the
other day and talking about and I'm sure
that you've been having similar
conversations with your teenage kids and
here all your kids but I think that
kovat has been especially frustrating
for teenagers because you just think
about what your life was like when you
were 16 and to have all these
restrictions put on you have so much
life learn and go like yeah you and you
you haven't lived most right and you're
like rust rating the summer of my 16th
year is well I gotta wear masks if I
want to be around my friends and I
thought and probably be outside with
them and like I have to ask them
questions about where they've been and
where their families have been it's like
this is incredibly frustrating
especially considering the fact that if
a teenager gets the coronavirus I mean
the chances of it being even even them
even knowing they've got it is pretty
small right it's like is this not gonna
affect them personally so it's this
completely almost completely like
selfless thing that they have to do and
so you know we've had a lot of
conversations about how difficult this
has been and the in the way that I gave
him some advice the other day is I was
like look towards the sunshine in the
shadows well that's what I should have
said but what what I said is like this
is not as good of advice as this cuz
it's not as simple but I was like you're
going through something right now and I
can write a story about it I can and I
can write to two different scripts right
and one script is that this is really
difficult and really restrictive and
your parents are taking this too
seriously
and you know all the negative things
that you can see but then there's the
positive side of the script which is
like when you look back on this should
be like I live through this really weird
time and it made me really my
friendships and we kind of went through
like all the the positive way that you
could the things that you could focus on
it's like you know your parents are
healthy you're healthy nobody that we
know has gotten this there's not other
other health conditions that were
already we're not nobody in our family's
immunocompromise like you start sort of
counting all your blessings and the
things that you have been privileged to
the position that you're in and you're
like oh okay that helps you turn towards
the positive and and then I was like
because your circumstances are not going
to change right like we're gonna be in
this for a while and if you're expecting
me to do something to make it okay for
you you're expecting your friends to do
something no the only thing that you can
do is you can write your own script you
can turn towards the sunshine turn away
from the darkness and I think that and
I'm I'm kind of giving myself that of
advice as I give it to him because we're
all going this has been difficult for
everybody right but to say like alright
where can I be grateful
what can I focus on because I got I have
a whole lot to be thankful for and when
I do that all of a sudden it's like okay
yeah this it's it's truly helpful the
black sheep responded to our prompt and
said life-changing advice was to always
remember saunder s o ND e r before
getting upset at somebody else over
petty things and then she put the
definition of saunder which i had never
heard that definition actually had this
pulled up not i don't wander is it now a
it is a company know that is like air
B&B but people never live in the homes
but it makes you it but it's
like a curated hotel and a home
experience that no one ever lived in
that ain't what we're talking about
because it was a term coined in 2012 by
John chorong or coning whose project the
dictionary of obscure sorrows aims to
come up with new words for emotions that
currently lack words and this one is
inspired by German saunder which means
special and French saunder which means
to probe and his definition is the
profound feeling of realizing that
everyone including strangers passed in
the street has a life as complex as
one's own which they are constantly
living despite one's personal lack of
awareness of it so and then the way go
back to the definition she posted it's a
little more succinct sonder noun the
realization that each random passerby is
living a life as vivid and complex as
your own the and I love this I want to
remember this word I must say it three
times
Thunder Thunder Thunder I've got it I'm
doubtful but it behind behind every face
there's a story look over sunder and
that is something that we've talked
about you know when you interact with
people you never know what's going on in
their life I tend to immediately think
about seeing strangers get angry like a
real Internet like a road rage situation
okay well we can talk about the internet
too but yes when you when you see
somebody or you read their their comment
or whatever it's tough not to just react
to how it impacts you or how it strikes
you even if it's just a passerby that it
is not impacting you at all
but this it's it's an it's a good
exercise to say and there's a there's a
story being lived out there there's that
person is going through something and
and when somebody does something that's
like a head-scratcher
or like worse like that person is
lashing out in anger just to stop and
sunder eyes it say you know what I've
been really angry before and sometimes
it's not justified but there were other
things going on my life that I knew
about her we didn't couldn't put my
finger on it's like just to have a
little a little pause for for compassion
and also when you are about to get angry
at someone for something mm-hmm right
when they say or do something meant
unintentionally intentionally or
otherwise when you think oh it's just
empathy right it's putting yourself in
somebody else your shoes it's just
understanding that yeah they and they
also are worried about the way that they
look and they sound to the same degree
that you are right everyone's a bit
obsessed with with themselves I know
that I'm gonna make mistakes in life I'm
gonna wrong people I'm gonna be you know
I'm gonna place my needs above other
people I'm gonna do things that I regret
regret and that I'm sorry for and I'm
gonna do things that are also
misinterpreted and can be misinterpreted
a lot worse than they actually were
mm-hm and I want people to to give me
the benefit of the doubt when entering
into a situation and a dialogue with me
about whatever mistake I made or
potentially made you know it goes a long
way for people to believe the best it's
like I don't know if you meant this when
you said it but it struck me in this way
or it seems like you said this I don't
know if that's what you intended is is
an example of opening a conversation
it's not like that is the worst thing
like that's stupid or that's ignorant or
it could just be a mistake or a
misunderstanding now believing the best
in some situations I think the best that
you can believe is still pretty bad in a
certain situation of course there are
people who do bad things like I say do
it or be held do it on purpose this is
not about excusing anyone now behavior
but believing in general believing the
best in people and applying that filter
whenever I find myself getting up in
arms you know
that saying implies that like you want
to attack right so and I think we get to
that with another piece of advice so
maybe I'll leave it at that but I do
want to just remember saunder and I
think it's a good for some reason I
because I don't live in New York and we
visit New York City okay like I always
think of that environment because you're
like walking around and you're you're
seeing so many faces I that's what I
picture with saunder is that like I'm on
a street corner
I'm always overwhelming to go back in a
good way that's like wow look at all
these people just moving with these the
traffic lights wherever when you get
behind every per behind every set of
eyes there's a story and just you know
there's there's something in that that
kind of makes me swell up with like
pride to be a human that's like like
there's so there's a vivid experience
there that I know nothing about yeah I
think about that one I'm on elevators
with people sometimes it's a fun it's a
fun practice I think it's a good habit
to cultivate and then I don't talk about
I don't talk to them I don't say
anything yeah I mean that's it could be
problematic being the elevator talker
but it is a good habit I think it puts
you in your place to like when you see
somebody say I wonder what their story
is and then it might be fun just to make
something up just in your own mind but
as long as you don't convince yourself
that's them and and say I can't believe
that you left the gate open on the tiger
cage at the well that's a zoo that's one
of my favorite things about that do+
brothers book oh yeah is how they will
sit in an airport next to each other and
they'll see somebody or a couple and
they begin basically saying who they
writing a screenplay writing a
screenplay let's get to another one
saunder Miranda Lemke mythical em key
always check air and fluid in your
vehicle before going on a long trip my
dad when I was learning how to drive
told me that oh yeah I love this yeah
like my
father-in-law everytime when Christy and
I were dating when we were first married
and we would visit like I would after
him hey nice to see you in greeting one
of the first things he would do I would
look back over my shoulder if we were
bringing in like our luggage and he'd
have the hood popped on the car that
just arrived that just a want you can do
that cuz it'd be hot it'd be too hot you
can't check the oil when it's hot but
III do remember finding him very early
on and he would he would have popped the
hood and he's checking the oil and a lot
of times would be like Christie you
haven't been checking the oil in the car
the oil is low and I started learning
before we would go there that I would
check the oil at the house because I
knew that he would do it you were like
the 14-point Jiffy Lube inspection at
Bobby's house well and especially when
you've got a car which because my dad
was very committed to dot the Dodge
brand for like throughout my entire
childhood Dodge Chrysler we we had to
dodge dynasties we had the Dodge
Intrepid there was a New Yorker you were
excited about that and trip but every
single one of these cars without fail
first of all if you got a Dodge the
transmissions going out at 100,000 miles
or earlier but it's net it's not making
it past that and then the second thing
is it starts burning oil at some point
like it burns oil to the point that you
have to keep oil in your car a quart and
so I remember in college driving that
intrepid in just checking the oil and
filling it up like gas yeah it was like
it's like you got you gas and you got
you all you got to take care of both of
them but it isn't as big of an issue
anymore I I don't think well the the
light I mean you get a more modern car
and it's got more lights that tell you
stuff and they blinking like I got to
put washer fluid in my car it's Bob it's
bugging me about that huh that's good I
mean better better to be bugged and to
be on the side of the road without
washer fluid and wipe off the bugs but
the thing that I I haven't
the habit of whenever I go to get in my
car I always look at the tires I think
one time I realized I've been driving
and like when my tires was really flat
many many years ago and it kind of
burned me well it's always a hard to
tell you that now they do yeah if you
get a fancy one but it's always nice to
just you know before you get in your
vehicle just walk around at once give it
the older rental the rental car walk
around look at those tires make sure
there's nothing dragging you know I
found a screw in my tire the other day
doing this yeah that's a pre-emptive
catch you can just you can drive to the
place and have them have a plug it they
plugged it up good old shell the velvet
hook here's this piece of advice you
can't control how people like but you
can can control did I just say can can
yeah you kind of did we don't know what
you meant you can't control how people
act but you can control how you react
this has helped me so many times in life
when deciding how to respond in
situations and it's made me more aware
of when I'm letting my reactions
overtake me oh this is good this is good
you can't you know control is such a big
part of my psyche that I this type of
advice is just great for me it's like I
find when I'm really anxious it's
because I want something to be a certain
way but I feel powerless and if I can
just parse between what I can actually
impact and what I have no control over
it really does help me Oh Linc you're
talking about the prayer for serenity
that many of you already know yeah god
grant me the serenity can you sing it or
chant it in a monkish kind of way I
don't know whatever god grant me the
to accept the things I cannot change the
courage to change the things I can and
the wisdom to know the difference
it's I didn't know that that thing went
on that's only a third of it that's the
only part that you need to know in this
context grant me the serenity to change
I gotta read it again cuz I was so
disappointed just sing it does see if
you can remember it okay I'll see if I
can remember it I was I was just
thinking about like that horrible melody
I think that that was pretty good for
like pulling a monk melody god great out
of here grant me the serenity to accept
the things I cannot change but change
the things I can't accept accept the
things I cannot change the courage to
change the things I can and the wisdom
to know the difference so that's the
parsing that you're talking about mmm
and uh boy man what if everybody I mean
first of all it's one thing to even to
know that you should be doing this I
just remember I wrote something what I
was I was like reflecting on this and I
thought I came up with something and I
wrote it down
and then I went back to look at it you
came out you like read arrived the
serenity prayer
this is how I wrote it in my like
digital journal some things you just
can't change other things you can some
things you think you can change but
can't and some things you don't think
you could have changed but you could
have those are the sad ones do you like
me to sing that I was yeah yeah I can do
that and don't read anything this is my
don't read any of that other stuff
because this is my freaking sure I see
it just as thoughts okay some things you
just can't change
other things you can
some things you think you can change but
you can't and some things you don't
think you could have changed but you
could have those are the sad sad war I
mean but and and I'm like I think this
may be just that just a perfectionist
like thinking there's a lot of thinking
going on in that lot too much thing but
it's like the worst thing is not
thinking you could change something and
you can't but thinking you couldn't
change something and you could but that
I think that may be torture for me
I don't know because once it's happened
you can't go back and change I'm not I
know I'm not talking about things in the
past you could exist you could have you
could have in the past yes and that's
sad that's bad those are the sad ones I
said around the thing about what you
could have done differently
that's just don't I think about all the
sad ones but I'm thinking about the next
thing it's like man I can't do anything
about this but if you could have done
something about it but you convinced
yourself you couldn't that's sad that's
the saddest yeah that's Saturday than
trying and not being able to change but
that's just futile well I wrote a book
that was I was gonna make it a wreck at
some point maybe I will in the future
but it's your wreck today I think it was
called the courage to be disliked and it
was all about Adlerian psychology I
think it think the guy's name was Joseph
Adler but he was basically a guy back in
the the time of Freud and Jung who you
know what ended up happening is like
Freudian psychology ended up kind of
winning out in terms of the way people
think about things but there was this
guy I guess Josef Adler who thought
differently about things and he was and
he had this mentality it's pretty
fascinating I don't even know what I
think about it but anyway
one of the principles in this book is
this idea of in every situation you
basically sort of revisit this parsing
that you're talking about this idea that
like I can only control myself I can
only control my actions my reactions and
I wish I could remember the term that he
used again I was gonna go back and look
at this before I ever talked about and
recommended it I hate doing this but
there was just this idea of what we what
we have such a tendency to do is we just
get confused with what our work is right
and this is especially this especially
relates to other people and you get into
these very codependent situations where
you're just like if this person would
just do this thing right if this person
would just react or react or behave in
this way then I would be okay and then
when you can kind of just release
yourself from that trying to get people
to do what you want them to do what you
expect them to do and realize that the
only the only sovereignty I have is over
my own actions and it's like it's but
it's just very freeing and it's so
difficult because there is this we do
believe that we can change people you
know and I mean it's tough because there
are people who specialize in helping
people change right like it's so like if
you think about my therapist well you
might change people but you can't
control well I mean the classic analogy
you can you know lead a horse to water
but you can't make them drink so I do
think that we get all the way sometimes
and we just want to force someone's
action but as it makes me think of as
what as she'll demonstrates it's it's
it's more about your if you focus on the
way that you react you'll be a lot
happier as George Strait saying you can
lead a heart to love but you can't make
it fall and I always thought that was a
very clunky song I mean it's like yeah I
get it you kind of like a
you're kind of like fall you can't make
it you can't make someone fall in love
with you it's again it's very clunky I'm
not a fan I think Bonnie Raitt said it
much better oh yeah that's a good song I
can't make you love me if you don't yeah
boy that's a good song that's her best
well I'm not gonna say it's the best
that's Bonnie Raitt's best song oh gosh
you named a second Bonnie Raitt song
exactly let's give him something to talk
about actually you know what you know
what I could I'm I I have a sense that
there's some Bonnie Raitt that we don't
know about that's really good some
second-rate Bonnie Raitt there's some
first-rate Bonnie Raitt so don't you be
talking about if you can't even name two
songs what her best song is turndown
I mean it's so good mates agree I mean
everything about it is just perfect I
mean Marc Cohn's best song is not
walking in Memphis well and that's I
don't want you I don't want you to make
that mistake
hello Marc all right Marc Cohn's walking
in Memphis is not even Marc and Marc
Cohn's top 15 songs exactly but I think
you're making it walking in Memphis
you're walking in Memphis right now I'm
walking and Bonnie Raitt I'm walking
down Bonnie Raitt way and I'm and I've
missed a turn
Keisha Johnson maybe it's Casey Johnson
I watched the TED talk by Celeste
Headley on how to have a good
conversation okay I like this my
favorite piece of advice she gives was
enter every conversation assuming you
have something to learn I highly
recommend this TED talk it's on YouTube
hashtag ear biscuits enter every
conversation assuming you have something
to learn humility I mean I'm really I
mean in light of what's going on and you
know I've really tried to with it with
the black lives matter movement
now just really really say you know what
I'm gonna listen I'm gonna learn and I'm
gonna make applications it's really it's
really top of mind for me in that way
but it's so important in general I think
it's it's it's not instinctive you know
it's instinctive to to just react in
okay
what is if someone saying something that
could impact me or reflect on me or is
someone making an assertion about me
well and and then you you you
instinctively take that in and then can
react defensively you know it's hard to
walk a mile in someone else's shoes it
takes it takes practice that have that
kind of mindset to step out of yourself
and how this whatever it is in whatever
issue impacts me in saying okay what
what is this person really saying what
can I learn in this conversation you
know I think when we go we've talked
about how we go into party settings and
we're like interacting with people and
you're having these little conversations
and the ones that are the most
stimulating to us are the ones that's
like when we have a mindset of when
somebody tells me what they do we talk
about I don't if you pump a septic tank
or if you're you're writing blockbuster
films you we should be able to have an
engaging conversation with each person
and I think it's because it's a little
bit of this mentality of there's always
a question to ask there's always
something to be learned you know it's
like anybody can say I'm a so and so or
I do this on reddit ask me anything and
underneath you will find rewarding
conversations but when people have that
mindset it's rewarding for everybody you
know people feel valued they'll feel
heard and you can learn something you
can learn something from a total [ __ ]
hmm well I do think that this is I mean
this is so applicable and I mean we're
you know we're just in the latest sort
of polarizing national
issue right I mean this has been going
on for a long time now and I mean the
dream of the internet connecting people
resulted in the internet dividing people
because now there's this democratization
of information and people have like
separated into these these information
bubbles and you you only talk with
people who agree with you and then when
you do get into these occasions where
you have a conversation with someone
that you disagree with the goal is not
to find the truth between your two
perspectives the goal is to entrench
yourself and defend your position and
all costs and I'm guilty of it you know
this is like you said it's she's kind of
human nature I was saying I'm thinking
about I don't know exactly how this
relates but this made me think of this
quote from Fight Club because I just
watched Fight Club recently with Locke
world number one don't talk about Fight
Club rule number two don't talk about
Fight Club rule number three it's
something about if you're new here you
have to fight if you're first I think
rule number four is if you're new if
you're first time you have to fight I
think we're number three is the fighting
goes until one person stops it or
something like that
I think there's only four I don't have
any rules our table wasn't where I was
gonna go but the thing that I realized
and this is true of David Fincher movies
in general I actually kind of regretted
not putting Fight Club on my top ten
list after watching it I don't know if
it would have made the top ten but you
just forget how many good lines are in
his movies it's a very I mean just
disclaimer it's a very visceral and
violent movie could be very disturbing
for some people yeah but it's not for
everyone
one of the things that Brad Pitt's
character says in the movie is you know
when you're dying people really really
listen to you instead of just waiting
for their turn to talk and and I don't
I'm not really talking about the dying
part but talking about just the default
of humans which is and I'm super guilty
of
is just waiting for my turn to talk
right you just oh I got something and
it's I mean it's it's one thing for it
that just happened in the context of a
friendship or like people hanging out
where it's just like oh now we're
telling poop yourself stories alright I
got mine yeah and those are fun those
stories are fun but also that kind of
conversation can be fun but I think
especially when you're talking about
something that you have a disagreement
about not like there's there's a concept
that I heard somebody described one time
you know you've got what typically
happens on line which is the straw man
which is you know you mischaracterize
someone's argument and you make it some
of you distill it down to something that
you can easily burn down take out yeah
but there's a different there the
opposite of that I think is called iron
Manning I don't know something like that
okay but it's like I'm going to
understand and be able to state your
position in the most defensible way I
can think of right I'm gonna give you
the benefit of the doubt I'm gonna try
to capture the essence of what you're
saying in a way that you can agree with
so that then when I disagree with it
you can hear my disagreement because you
know you've been heard yeah but but also
there's just something there's just
something about like just making
yourself willing to go through the
process of being like okay before I just
get going to my talking points and break
out my ideology I am going to understand
and be able to say things like so you're
saying if I'm hearing you correctly
you're saying this this and this and if
they say no that's not what I'm saying
keep listening and then if you can
finally get to you're saying this this
and this yes even if you disagree
there's progress that's been made
there's some kind of common ground
because you've at least agreed to have a
rational conversation about something
you know and that's just such is such a
difficult thing to do
yeah I mean I quoted George Strait now
I'll quote
went black put yourself in my shoes
welcome out for me yeah I'll put myself
in your shoes and maybe then we'd see
that if you put yourself in my shoes
you'd have some sympathy and if I put
myself in your shoes I'd walk right back
to me oh it was a relationship that's a
good song I mean it was a good song yeah
I don't know he's got a new album I'm
not gonna listen to it
Clint black does yeah yeah I mean I I
don't know ever since he was on the
apprentice yeah I have a different like
once I saw not about Clint Black
unplugged completely okay all right yeah
and it has nothing to do with Trump or
The Apprentice right who Clint Black
yeah I mean it's not that he's not uh
he's not like it's not like I don't like
him necessarily it's just he isn't the
person that his songs made him out to be
it's you get what I'm saying there's
first two albums killing time and I
think it's putting some writing songs
yeah yeah yeah he wrote some good songs
on those two albums Beth Ann Smith says
after my grandfather died my mom found a
piece of paper tucked in the phone book
why I asked classic haven't haven't
having a note tucked in a phone book man
remember phone books you can still get
him sometimes I'll drop him off of your
driveway uh he had written and then
tucked into the notebook quote today
invest in someone else's happiness
end quote and then Beth Ann said I think
about those words almost every single
day I I love the fact that Beth and that
you can you can carry this meaningful
part of your grandfather with you at all
times and you know I I picture him
riding that and it was an it was kind of
a note to self you know he probably went
to the
book a lot you know we forget how often
you went to the phone book every time
you had to get in contact with somebody
I mean I I had certain numbers memorized
and then you had you know with the
advent of the speed dial but a lot of
times you would I mean even his kids we
would go to the phone book a lot not
just for people but for places oh yeah
you got a page yeah the yellow part in
the back you know anything any you
talked about Yelp the yellow the yellow
pages was the Yelp you had a judge a
plumber by his add yeah there were no
reviews it was just the number part like
did this plumber look smart so it's
whenever he was interacting and it's you
know it's think about this he was about
to make phone a phone call he was about
to have an interaction with somebody it
could be a business it could be a loved
one it could be a complete stranger you
know someone where he needed to
accomplish something in some way he was
gonna make a phone call to do that right
and then right there in front of him was
is a reminder to himself invest in
someone else's happiness and here's an
opportunity right now it can be
something as simple as I'm calling you
for this reason a but by the way B I can
say hello something to make you happy I
can crack a joke I can be smiling on the
phone and then you might change the tone
of the way yeah okay well the thing that
it makes me think about is I feel like I
know nothing about Beth Ann's
grandfather right I've never met the man
all I know is that he put this note into
a phone book yeah but I know a lot about
him because of that right yeah I know
that whether he was like this his entire
life or he came to the conclusion later
in life that this is actually where his
happiness his true happiness lied right
is in investing as somebody else's
happiness and this I mean man it's just
it's such good advice because everybody
needs it and we're all very naturally
resistant to understanding that because
your natural impulse is to invest in
your own happiness right it's it's it's
to look out for yourself is to think
about your circumstances but when it's
is that we talked about the hole that I
the first mountain in the second
mountain you know the first mountain in
life being about you getting to the top
of whatever your goals are and then if
you fall off that mountain or you get to
the top this is that David books book
and and then you're like oh there's
another mountain I should have been on
and that's the mountain of investing in
other people and if you can get there at
some point and make your life where it
shifts from your interest that can be
our get happen with this with her
grandfather rewarding and you know the
phrase pay it forward comes to mind the
thing that I don't love about that is it
implies that you've received something
good and now it's a reminder to give it
I I'm you know I shouldn't pick it apart
I'm sure it's it's a great phrase and is
a good mantra but the thing I like about
this is it's not contingent on your
experience to invest in someone else's
happiness but what when you do benefit
from from someone enriching your life I
do think it's a good trigger to say how
can i how can I take this experience
that was given to me and and we gift it
or also gift it is I don't even have to
give up my experience to give another
one but the thing about is it's
interesting here it doesn't say today
make someone happy you know he says
today invest in someone else's happiness
I think a lot of times there there are
people who you you know you can't it
would be a magical ability to just make
everybody happy I mean that's just the
work of clowns some good clowns I mean I
would say the small percentage of clowns
right
I'm sorry clowns just it's just the way
it is but invent I mean an investment
and to me it makes me think that even if
you can't make someone happy in the
moment you can you can do something that
at least sews a seed of happiness down
the road for them so well and also in
the context of you I mean he's got it in
the phone book and we're talking about
it in the context with like people that
you interact with
you know acquaintances or whatever but I
also think about it in terms of your
closest relationships that you have
right so mm-hmm I think about the days
that I get home it's funny I was
thinking about getting home too because
we haven't been getting home right as
we've been at homes like that but we're
starting at you so yeah thinking about
it more I get home and I walk into the
house I see Jesse and I think that a lot
of times my disposition is how is her
presence or was something that she says
can she say or do something that makes
me okay with something that happened to
me today
right like I'm coming into the house
thinking about what I can get from her
part of it is the fact that Barbara
greets me at the door and Barbara is all
about what she can give to me you know
invest yeah you're willing to receive an
investment in your happiness but if I
went in and my mentality was regardless
of how bad my day was I'm going in with
the mindset of like invest in her
happiness and again you can actually be
you can actually do it for selfish
reasons I mean just to be completely
transparent like if you're like because
ultimately the weird thing about this is
you kind of go full circle and it's like
this will make you happier I think
that's the beauty of it I don't think
that's that's not the motivation I'm
just saying but the net result is if you
go in with that surprise surprise you
will end up being happier ultimately
yeah and I think because we are getting
out more than our families are you know
we're in here connecting having this
conversation this is I mean this is an
investment in our happiness right we
we're getting built up in a way that
like they're not leaving the house as
much as we are so when when we go back
to our families it's like hey I'm I'm
bringing an energy that is hard to just
create when you're at home all the time
yeah so starting to have more of that
mentality I think yourself oh boy all of
this I thank you for sharing all this
advice
yeah there's more that we heard talk
talk about these we'll talk about
another time these these farts are
really smelling good yeah see that's I
just don't like the analogy I'm gonna
make a recommendation because wreck baby
wrecked baby 1 2 3 it's that time it's
the end of the episode I want to
recommend that you listen to
strange fruit by Billie Holiday I was
not I didn't know about this song time
call in 1999 time called this song Time
magazine said strange fruit was the best
song of the century you know that they
named it that at the turn of the century
it was recorded by Billie Holiday Inn in
1939 it was written by Abel Meeropol two
years earlier it protests the lynching
of black Americans with lyrics that
compare the victims to the fruit of
trees and if you want to read about all
this just go to the Wikipedia that's
where I'm getting this information but
it it's a powerful song in this time it
puts yourself in the shoes of someone
looking at a photograph of of a lynching
that happened in Indiana on August 7th
1930
I mean upwards of 5,000 black Americans
died as a result of lynching and there
are photographs of people just there are
postcards yeah of of people celebrating
and having picnics in the presence of
black people being hung from trees as if
it's like look at the great thing that
we did it's absolutely horrifying but
through this song I mean it it turned
out to be Billie Holiday's most popular
song and it was sold nuts sold over a
million
records and you know it was it was a
huge it was a huge risk in her career of
course she was advised not to do what
she was very relegated regulated in the
way she could do it she had to be let
out of her recording contract to record
this song as an exception and then it
became her her most popular song it's
extremely moving again it's another way
to to stare into the face of this the
the horror of racism and and deal with
it well it's kind of a small example of
what I see so often online when anybody
who's an artist of any kind entertainer
says anything with conviction that might
be interpreted as political there's this
shut up and sing you know shut up and
dance shut up and would do whatever it
is that you do and I love it when an
artist takes that and actually turns it
back on the people who say that and
through their art does something that is
that paints the picture in a stark and
sort of heart-wrenching way yeah I mean
this is on the playlist that Britt and I
created
if you don't know ever give or take
every week on a Saturday night we do we
do a listening party for each other
that's different themes and we did a
theme of songs for change this is on
that playlist so you can go to my
Instagram and click on the IG TV tab and
see see all of those episodes but
specifically this one go to my Spotify I
got all the songs for up I mean that's
your laptop the menu closing no I'll be
okay
go to my spot you don't need it there
you go is gone I got all types of
playlists
now you're shown on your Spotify I can't
get on me about shout no I got it I
stuff I long tie all II did it so that
you would say that
strange fruit by Billie Holiday that's
really what you need to listen to thank
you for listening thank you for the
advice that was given to you that then
you shared with us and hopefully the
conversation about it
spread all the love and the advice
around in all the right places
invest in someone's happiness today is
what you make it we'll we'll talk out
you in a few weeks
enjoyed the break from us but don't
forget about hash tag your biscuits to
watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best